Ellaria Sand: Before the Seven Kingdoms, before
the Iron Throne, there was Dorne. Twelve thousand
years ago, the First Men crossed the land
bridge from Essos to here. Of course, they
were men, so they soon broke it.
Then, while their cousins to the North built
kingdoms, the Dornish squabbled over land,
water, and wives for centuries. Until Nymeria,
a warrior princess in Essos.
She led a fleet of ten thousand ships across
the Narrow Sea to Dorne. Almost all of the
petty lords made it clear that she wasn't
welcome. All but one. Mors of House Martell.
He saw in her a strength to match any man,
including his rivals. After she accepted his
marriage offer, she set fire
to her ships. For
fifty leagues, the coast was bright as day,
and in the burning light, Princess Nymeria
named Mors Martell the Prince of Dorne, in
the style of her people. Dorne would be her
home or her grave.
For many years, Nymeria and Mors waged war
against all rivals. The Jordaynes, Blackmonts,
Qorgyles, and even the mighty House Yronwood.
They sent no fewer than six self-styled "kings"
to the Wall in golden chains. After Mors fell
in battle, Nymeria took command of his armies
and united Dorne in two years.
She ruled for twenty-seven more, and though
she married again, those husbands were little
more than councilors and consorts. Dorne was
Nymeria, and Nymeria was Dorne.
She survived a dozen attempts on her life,
put down two rebellions, and threw back two
invasions. And when at last, she died, her
eldest child succeeded her (her daughter,
not her son), and Dorne followed her because
Nymeria had proven that women were equal to
men, if not better.
"Unbowed, unbent, unbroken." The words of
House Martell. The words of Dorne. Men may
forget, but women always remember. When we
were divided, Nymeria united us. When we were
invaded, Meria defended us.
Varys: Westeros has mighty rivers, but none
of them compare to the Rhoyne. It is said
that there is no stream or puddle in western
Essos but drains to Mother Rhoyne. No doubt,
an exaggeration. Until one sees the river.
At its widest, a man in the center can't see
a shore to either side. The greatest of Mother
Rhoyne's children were the Rhoynar, a civilization
as ancient and grand as Old Ghis.
Fishers, traders, scholars, workers of wood,
stone, and metal, the Rhoynar raised their
elegant cities from the headwaters of the
Rhoyne down to her mouth, each lovelier than
the last.
For many centuries, the Rhoynar lived in relative
peace. When invaders swept down from the hills,
the Rhoynar women and men would don silver-scaled
armor, fish head helms, tall spears, and turtle
shell shields.
If the enemy did not laugh themselves away,
it was said that Mother Rhoyne would whisper
the enemy's secrets to her children, and the
Rhoynish wizards could raise watery walls
to drown their foes.
Whatever magic the Rhoynar may have had, it
wasn't enough. When Valyrian colonists first
arrived, the Rhoynar embraced them, for all
men were welcome to share the bounty of Mother
Rhoyne.
Perhaps a water people should have been more
cautious of strangers who exulted fire and
blood. Legend has it that one day the Valyrians
netted and butchered one of the giant turtles
the Rhoynar held sacred.
As a result, thousands were killed or enslaved,
cities and towns were burned, drowned, and
rebuilt. In these wars, the Valyrians emerged
as victorious more often than not.
The princes of the Rhoynish cities, fiercely
proud of their independence, fought alone,
whilst the Valyrian colonies aided one another.
Eventually, the Rhoynish princes ceased their
squabbling and united behind Prince Garin,
who led the largest army Essos had ever seen
against 100,000 Valyrian colonists, 100 war
elephants, and three dragonlords.
Thousands burned, but thousands more sheltered
in the shallows of the river whilst the Rhoynish
wizards raised enormous water spouts against
the foes' dragons.
Rhoynish archers brought down two of the dragons
whilst the third fled wounded, and thereafter
the Rhoynar named Garin "the Great."
But Mother Valyria proved just as caring as
Mother Rhoyne. When Garin the Great marched
his army against Volantis, three hundred Valyrian
dragons descended from the sky.
Tens of thousands burned whilst others rushed
into the river.
But the fire burned so hot that the waters
boiled and turned to steam. Garin the Great
was captured alive and made to watch as Valyrians
butchered every last man, so many that their
blood turned the great harbor of Volantis
red as far as the eye could see.
Then they forced Garin to watch as they marched
on his own city and enslaved all the women
and children his army had left behind.
The singers claimed that Prince Garin called
out Mother Rhoyne to curse the Valyrians,
and she, in turn, flooded the city with foul
waters and a damp fog that caused the skin
of the Valyrians to harden and crack, and
thus was born greyscale.
Qyburn: Few afflictions are more feared than
greyscale, and far past the point of reason.
A legend calls it "Prince Garin's curse,"
after an ancient eastern prince whom the Valyrians
hung in a cage and forced to watch the immolation
of his city and people.
As his city burned under dragonflame, this
prince called on his god for vengeance, and
a thick fog of foul humors rose from the Rhoyne
to smother the Valyrians with greyscale.
But if diseases could be called down by the
vengeful, we would have no health in the world.
More likely the disease predates the Valyrians
entirely, confined to some remote region of
Essos, and only spread throughout the world
once the Valyrians linked the continent with
roads and dragons.
Fearing a similar fate, another Rhoynish ruler,
Princess Nymeria, led her own people into
every ship, skiff, and raft they had and fled
Essos. Eventually, after much hardship, they
landed in sunswept and bone dry Dorne.
Oberyn Martell: "Unbowed, Unbent, Unbroken."
The words of House Martell. A promise to our
enemies and a challenge to our lovers.
Thousands of years ago, the warrior queen
Nymeria crossed into Dorne from Essos, fleeing
the dragonlords of Valyria. After she landed,
she burned her ships, all ten thousand of
them, so no cowards could slink home.
What a woman. Dornish in spirit before she
ever was in flesh.
She was lucky to land in Dorne, where powerful
women are not locked away in septs and the
beds of old men. My ancestor, Mors Martell,
saw her and desired her, and proved that where
armies fail, a tongue may succeed.
Wedding his strength to hers, his spear to
her sun, they subdued all of his rivals together.
After the tradition of her people, House Martell
then ruled Dorne as Princes, not kings, unless
the eldest child was a daughter.
For unlike the rest of Westeros, our loyalty
is not commanded by a c***. We follow a Prince
or a Princess Martell just
the same.